greetings from podcast Ville it's
Wednesday the 16th the [ __ ]
October the church or what's happening
now is brought to you by let me talk to
you people from the heart
I've even bumped into a porno by mistake
and the chief got a really really really
really really hairy [ __ ] yeah it's a
[ __ ] you want to dive in at first but
there's something about that [ __ ]
cobweb mixed with spiders you don't know
what the [ __ ] that is you don't saying
we have the same thing as men if you
look at yourself in the mirror and truly
look at your dick and look what's
growing on your dick you're gonna go
looks like the [ __ ] outside of the
month this house they just call my dick
1313 Mockingbird lanes this is
disgusting there's tumbleweeds there
[ __ ] growing under your [ __ ] hair a
turtleneck just like mine I'm not gonna
lie nobody I don't condition my dick and
it's out of whack
it looks like [ __ ] Lucille Ball play
what the chemistry said but that [ __ ]
ends it's trick-or-treat [ __ ] if
you want to sling out [ __ ] candy and
these [ __ ] sucking on your tailpipe
on Halloween
you gotta trim the bush with [ __ ]
manscaped listen my friends over at
manscaped created the one and only tool
you need to change your balls and the
area around your [ __ ] Halloween stick
with it's called the low important boom
or 2.0 for a reason
they threw away with the 1.0 and
upgraded that trimmer with a skin safe
technology listen it's gonna be the
integral of munch Alan lean party a
little older you don't have time to take
him to my hotel and [ __ ] him in the ass
but there's nothing nothing wrong
getting a little big suck from [ __ ]
you know some blonde bombshell dressed
up is Charlize Theron in that movie she
wants to walk long pills he as long as
he's got a sucky dick you take me in the
back and you give it a little punch and
ba-ba-boom you're ready and then when
she walks out he's got a smile on her
face why cuz she didn't smell death on
Halloween she's not a nice dick that had
no [ __ ] hummus smell to it or nothing
go to manscape doctor I'm right now I'm
gonna give you 20% off your first
daughter when you use Coke promo code
Church at man skate dot-com and if you
order the pepper kit the perfect package
will I blame later don't throw in a free
back when you use code Church CH you are
CH that's manscape calm use promo code
Church CH you are CH for 20% of your
first toilet
keep your balls and your [ __ ]
Halloween stick clean the church is also
brought to you by how many times I gotta
tell you [ __ ] my book you're going
into the heat a baseball [ __ ] playoffs
right now and you've been sitting there
scratching your [ __ ] ass what are you
thinking and you watch the games anyway
but I'm listenin if you're trying to bet
NFL baseball MMA UFC Chinese ping-pong
my bookies got it they gotta better
incentives and more [ __ ] lines and any
other sports book period listen double
your first deposit today use promo code
Church to get 100% bonus on your initial
deposit up to $1,000 what are you
[ __ ] waiting for visit my bookie dot
AG today that's my bookie grab a pad and
I know you got left back in the 6th
grade yeah you were definitely one hear
hear my bo o ki e dot AG and don't
forget to use promo code Church when
creating your account to claim this
[ __ ] bonus alright go win some money
you [ __ ] you play you win you get
mother [ __ ] baby Jack Lee take this
[ __ ] that meal once and for all
this is like the back of five of the
Batman's Carly pull up flames that come
on that jet engine you start with a jet
engine I like that freakin I'm a
pleasure to have you
oh thanks for having me to be on this
podcast for a long time it's been you I
appreciate it and here we are you
shooting you for a special walking
calmly on Friday yeah Thursday night a
little blessing from how and [ __ ] now
the King of Comedy Bill burr yeah
they're they're helping me out they're
really good people they aren't me hell
they're doing great things with awesome
Tommy came back from you city the
upgrade City when I was acute 39 great
barbecue like I was telling you before
the show nothing wrong with me when
somebody thinks they're smart all this
warming and they talk to you about how
they going to the France or Bali or some
[ __ ] yeah it's all great we'll go to
Kansas City first you know I think if I
was president United State
so be a xxx state requirement before you
were able to leave the United States to
check out you have to vid or con we have
to offer
yeah well you go dropping your money
over there with those commie bastards my
my mom went to Europe for the she left
America for the first time ever this
last summer she wanted my sister to go
watch the women's soccer games in France
whatever my dad did not go cuz he said
now there's there's still too much in
America I want to see so he's he's full
blooded American with me I think that's
the biggest blessing that I've gotten
from comedy that I've gotten to see what
we're really about as American people
yeah you know I know when I see when I
see these people around my neighborhood
that raised their kids a certain way
then two weeks later I'm and Kansas City
st. Louis you know yeah I'm in a part of
the country real America and you see how
people act how people you know these
people don't take care of themselves
yeah it's people's ankles look like
they're about to die like thought you
know but then nice people warms no it's
real nice to go to breakfast and to look
at your tab and it's seven dollars and
87 cents yeah and you look like you're
robbing the joint you looking around at
cameras just half but says they got you
they must not stop right you walk
through our tab and you look at it you
see two eggs bacon on fries and a toast
coffee included right you know take a
cup to go yeah I see like wow I live in
Atlanta well this is $22 yeah I get that
$45 brunchy yeah like it's literally
just kale and your egg whites yeah no
you see what America who's still holdin
it down you see no you don't pay the tax
bracket we we were discussing this two
days ago the tax brackets that we back
so it's pretty interesting it's also
interesting to see how Kansas City is a
comedy town but there's still there were
Chiefs people at the airport with full
chief regalia on Thursday night like the
employees yeah
then Friday when I went to q39
around the city I saw more [ __ ] red
shirts red Friday red Friday yeah
tremendous and you like if they act like
this in the Friday one of these savages
act like on a [ __ ] Sunday
yeah they they're out of control
tremendous a couple years ago they won
the World Series
I saw how emotionally you were and I
looked into it was the last time they
want yeah 30 years I stole them but
everybody used to hit great home runs at
the old Kansas City where the water
fountain is we still got it
well that's the stadium they just they
just rebuilt it instead of when I was a
kid every time somebody hit a good home
run there was that that [ __ ] Stadium
yeah like Pete Rose played there Johnny
Bench played there yeah and that would
that stadium has still a lot of [ __ ]
history yeah and the Royals and the
Yankees were like rivals 70s and 80s
yeah so is the American League West
versus American League East and I know
not everyone likes sports no not you
know have to like sports but like I
still get choked up like there's a guy
on the Celtics now named taco who's
there going quite like when they go
crazy like I remember for that Kansas
City World Series it was a guy from like
Japan or China or something the Korean
he was a Korean Korean they flew him in
and yeah he just leave he fell in love
with the team and the city fell in love
with him like when when they're like
that's how I know I like the city like
when like the stadium is full at the
beginning and it's full the end yeah
like small stuff like that we don't do
that
yeah night when the Dodgers when they
hit the Grand Slam you can see people
there are yellow seats all throughout
the other stadium so you could see
people leaving and that has to how it's
like when you do a UFC in Vegas yeah
it's the last fight you think those two
seats next to your empty you tell your
buddies come down and you'll see some
guy come in for the last fight right go
through that same you will see fighting
the prelims its back that prelim time
right those people play 298,000 every
minute that's coming yeah you never
saying they get out every minute that's
coming them yeah middle at middle
America don't [ __ ] around this pours you
know because that that's what they have
to do texts all week text yeah it's just
I love it I love this time of the year I
love to see the college you know I'm not
I don't know who's blame when yeah I
just know that if I sit down
I see two teams I go all
[ __ ] it's an old rivalry you know right
stage whatever
Colorado Nebraska that's that's the
country man yeah if you get people
talking [ __ ] I'm in I'm in yeah speaking
of talking [ __ ] I taught you leavin
lizard meat all the time I think
actually mouths meat last night so
excited you sorry you know me I talk
about my success is limited and I speak
about my failures on this podcast but I
have an excuse like when we used to go
get the lizard meet over at that taco
place he had been warned okay he had
been warned repeatedly and hi you back
called back he kept going back his
father ended up in the hospital never
been the same again it doesn't matter if
Lee's eating at it they got lizard meat
[ __ ] Lee there's a Cuban thing called
boletos did tremendous what are the most
you need a thousand oh of course
it's this [ __ ] thing they make like
ham spread on white bread and they cut
the edges off and they're all triangles
and they cut them in half and you go to
a Cuban birthday party they got tables
full and they have like little olives
and that's like a pimento loaf
okay and you start eating them when
you're high and you just can't stop and
the next thing is [ __ ] and [ __ ] see
them all the permant those you know
those little red jams they cover around
your [ __ ] so I told my wife around this
earth there's a webpage there's a
Facebook page called all things Cuban
and they had a recipe for it so I sent
it to my wife and I don't include the
deviled ham
does anybody know I've never heard of it
exactly that's how [ __ ] you don't
even want to know it sounds like it
sounds authentic the devil ham was big
in the 70s it was a spread that you just
put on bread and you ate it it really
tastes like Vienna sausages crush down
but god knows what has crushed him like
that's why don't I compass because
everybody thinks it just got Bonzo's I
don't know it's Isis sperm and it's like
the [ __ ] yeah yeah powder from the
chair yeah you eat that hummus no this
doesn't taste the same not because
there's no Isis so just wet that's
that's what they're trying to do we get
into the DNA smarter radicalize you for
the next thing you know you [ __ ]
Nealon [ __ ] praying at lunchtime you
know I'm saying I've seen it a thousand
times the last time about six o'clock
it's one day nighttime off I popped 300
milligrams of those capsules i'm solo
i'm watching the washington senators
whatever - then they get the [ __ ] out of
the same room yeah
and finally my daughter goes to bed my
wife goes to bed it's 9:15 what a great
time to write 11 o'clock sun's Aniki
comes up it gives me now 45 to take care
of just little things i want to write
out a joke and whatever oh my god I'm on
weight-wise it's helping them put a
banana
no biggie still Apple ooh doing over it
not doing it now and I got a protein bar
boom that filled me up for a little
while but I need the sandwich yeah go on
the cabinet hits some substance my wife
doesn't get no more cold cuts no cold
cut [ __ ] things like the last eight
months so come one salami salami was my
save yet night before son zanuck evil
salami cool American cheese on white
bread mustn't know biggest enemies but
there's nothing this [ __ ] hot those I
don't know how to use the stove hates
those so I look at your tablet the
cabinet behold she actually went and
bought the recipe for that thing there
was that [ __ ] double damn took it out
popped it open just spread it on white
bread as I was eating it the first two
bytes were marijuana-based yeah but by
the time I got to the third bite it
started tasting weird that tasted
rodents just a little bit yeah but
everything else is just bad yeah I took
the can away I threw the
right away I made toast and with the bed
my grandpa used to refer to mystery
things like that is it's it's nothing
but lips and [ __ ] that's all of it
yeah and they give it to you in prison
mental institutions after you're on the
white side of life to a devil and the
potato chips we're going deep into the
murky water not eating spam tonight my
eyes just open the fire gets walked over
first you trying to get coffee to really
open it up I do I had an apple a banana
net it's right knew I was safe that's
when you're covered you get all right
little loophole was there to [ __ ]
open up the [ __ ] I drank a coffee
couldn't even finish the coffee had to
run to the bathroom and it was one of
those 20 minute bricks to come out oh
yeah well once the brick came out it was
like pop I was like I'm like a [ __ ]
demolition derby then I got out and it
started squirting like I started
squirting oh I had to squirt last 15
minutes
I did another Express that'll get that
little baby rat foot sure maybe it was
like a claw that got caught yeah a
little Talon hooked in there so and how
much did you eat like how many scoops to
read bite that's it oh my god [ __ ] of
half the can but it was like I just made
a thin sand was just a testing ground
we're talking like bubonic plague rat me
no I mean this is [ __ ] nasty guy I
get destroyed my internal systems the
devil cancel my Lana Clark boxing class
I gotta cancel my not cuz I kept playing
it out let me say I feel it dead right
at ten I was feeling then I started
puking when I had a [ __ ] you first found
my puke breakfast and I go that's it I
cancel my 11:00 o'clock doctors and I
[ __ ] went and laid down that's how I
tested if someone doesn't taste good
when you're high
that's how you know it's not good it's
not yes it was rational a boy just
something that you brought from your
childhood
yeah that does not work any well of your
body the problem they probably don't
make it anymore so it's probably a jar
from your childhood
let's don't make haste a minute it's big
inspector you added two dishes right
white people a lot of white people
Midwest yeah this it makes him feel
cultured when you go to prison you week
that [ __ ] once a week all right
you could order that from the commissary
goddess of deviled ham that night at CBS
and it's like I think I've seen that it
knows a spread white can with a devil on
it with a little devil on that's how you
know but where the devil that devil got
into me this morning like The Exorcist
I'm surprised my head didn't split Stan
he's trying to tear through he's [ __ ]
Christ my I was it was bad I went to
sleep about 10:45 I got up at 12:30
jumped in the shower shaved got out
that's the chicken Superman who hit by
one took two - bonnets I'm surprised
they didn't get a call from me - no yeah
I was out cold he was busy surviving it
sounds like I got a big day yeah I got
spots at the store there's the last day
you really want to [ __ ] get sick so
yeah Thursday night Thursday night one
hour
yeah I'm gonna do an hour and yeah I
mean it's just it's hard for me to get
opportunities to do extended time
especially in LA so I kind of been
talking to you know Brenton over at all
things comedy about trying to work
something out and he hit me up a couple
weeks ago I was like hey you know we got
this date at the Comedy Store would you
want to do it then and I said sure so
gonna get a couple cameras and and just
try and catch some of that magic because
you know the comedy stores I mean it's
it's an incredible lineup to every not
did you start in Kansas City yeah I'd am
on stage yeah I did I didn't open my
Kansas City for like two years when I
was in college Stanford and Suns in down
in Westport in Kansas City the late
Craig glaziers comedy club back then and
you know his we like I started Chris
Porter was doing the open mikes back
then there a guy named Mike Baldwin my
buddy John shizer
pretty much the same see see the same
people Dustin Kaufman the guy who now
owns a comedy club in Kansas City and
but it's like I could get up once maybe
twice a week and I you know I was I
wanted to be on Saturday Night Live back
then so I did impressions and [ __ ] like
that
and always had my playin though you know
I wanted to move to New York or LA as
soon as I was old enough to get into the
clubs so I was just kind of wasting time
in college until I turned 21 and once I
turned 21 started making the plan to
move and you know lucked into a
situation where my my girlfriend at the
time cheated on me and that really
motivated me to get the [ __ ] out as well
so things just kind of fell into place
and moved out here I actually came out
for a weekend over Christmas the year
before I moved out comic name freeze
love yeah he some some sort of a friend
of a friend told me to go down to the
comedy store and meet this guy named
freeze love and he would show me around
the comedy clubs or whatever so I went
down there I was only 20 couldn't get in
the club kind of was hanging out on the
patio free showed up talked to me for a
little bit he said well let's go in I
said yeah they they won't let me in he
said oh you're with me now it's cool
walk by the back door guy guy said yeah
you doesn't have an ID and fries said
Danny Dunn need one and we just walked
right past them they let me in perform
to the belly room I was hooked I'm like
oh this is oh you did before yeah they
let me perform I did like seven minutes
the end of a show up there like right
around midnight or something ten people
and never even went to New York I was so
enamored by Los Angeles and end of
December it was like 75 degrees and I'm
just loving it got to perform and moved
out fall into the end of the following
summer came I was still 21 started
working the door I did open mikes Comedy
Store The Laugh Factory all that
[ __ ] was this 2002 okay so you know
I do the sit outside all day waiting to
do the open mics and
rent is easy and Eleanor asked me if I
wanted a job there and started working
the door there and I was working the
door there
what a great six nights a week and I was
my all-time favorite do a staff yeah I
was a young group re yeah
Skippy Simon I can rent his easy cap cap
yeah yeah yeah
Duncan was a talent coordinator Duncan
when I got past when Mitzi passed me I
it was a complete fluke it was I'd
worked the door there for maybe four
months
I had like maybe five minutes of okay
material but Mitzi just saw something
and was like oh you're a regular but I
was I was showcasing to keep my job as a
doorman so I didn't even think like hey
I might become a paid regular tonight
and Duncan was sitting with her cuz
Duncan's talent coordinator so Duncan
comes down hey man you want you to be a
regular you know and knowing Duncan I'm
just like goddammit Duncan's [ __ ] with
me
and so I truthfully didn't think it was
real at all like at no point was I like
this might be legit it's just like still
[ __ ] up the new guy so and he's like
yeah calling your avails tomorrow my all
right man and then the next day the
Comedy Store called me and I said yeah
you're gonna put in your veils I was
like what this is real
and then Duncan why do you think I was
[ __ ] with you cuz you're Duncan your
Duncan Trussell why wouldn't I think you
were [ __ ] with me and then Mitzi gave
me a spot immediately opening the show
and then just bombed so hard for eight
people or whatever the first night was
you know no no no no let's hear yeah I
thank God yeah I'd remember I did my my
five minutes and then then I'm just
trying to throw [ __ ] at the wall and as
soon as that light came on I was so
excited just to bring up Argos and not
have to perform anymore and then are you
oh wow you know we bring up a lot of
young pups here at the club and you know
tried to smooth things over basically
being like you know he's a kid give him
give him some slack at that time he had
seen it all yeah yeah
that time he had seen it all and I
talked to him a bunch kiss you know I
was the door guy so you know he'd get
their 15 minutes for set and tell us old
stories and stuff so he he covered for
me
and then knits he would just give me
opening spots for the first year so and
then a couple times she was there she'd
watch me it was nerve-wracking but
should always be flagging with him when
you bomb and she'd watch it oh I've done
I'm done I might as well move you got in
your car yeah I better look around for
this is the last yeah I couldn't even do
that I feel this back to the back door I
still live by that code even though
she's got yeah if I could have a bad
night I'm like she knows [ __ ] Adams
not gonna call there's no just it's such
a psychological beating yeah that we'd
give ourselves when she was around on
Saturday nights it used to just destroy
like the first one for three or two
months doing it I'd pray the Dow yeah
I'm gonna go see fat baby yeah that's I
remember that I remember be like who's
fat baby they be on the lineup and she'd
like she put you last so yeah baby
that's what she wants Joey Diaz to go by
yeah I just go up and destroy his fat
baby I thought that was just turning him
for you she wanted you to go by that it
was on the lineup fat baby oh no I
posted an old line up a couple months
ago and the first thing people know it's
like who's fat baby am I so Mitzi so she
called Joey Diaz what they make you
bring like coming up next to the stage
fat baby okay thank God the comics they
almost yo okay but [ __ ] he was there
then you had to do it Mitch why and I
even saw him once to go up in a giant
diaper me yeah do that
yeah no shirt on I mean literally
destroy the room and at a time when
people weren't destroying around because
comedy was in a very grave situation and
redhots early 2000 it was 2002 2003
people are not looking to laugh they
were not they were not going to the
store no one was there nobody and it was
post 9/11 so everyone is just like yeah
I don't know things aren't good but it
was it was tough times if I got a pre
9/11 was funny in that place just robbed
it up of I on Sunday it's so good
just robber to provide on Sundays people
have to understand that that's one of
those comedy store specific things that
people who've been around like actually
been around yeah because I remember
Robin Williams coming in one night he
was doing press for RV and this was he
was there like two nights in a five
month period of time one was my 25th
birthday where I just got hammered with
them and then the next day people were
like you know he was sober right I was
like oh [ __ ] and you drank one I drank
smoked I mean we got [ __ ] hammered
and you get down and I was like this is
the most waste I've been in 30 years I'm
like cool man I'm not thinking anything
of it next night dombarris it's like I
was telling Jimmy Kimmel about you guys
last night and you know he said Robins
been in you know he's been sober for
decades I'm like oh [ __ ] me no one said
anything I just thought we were having
fun and then he came back a couple
months later and you know I said look
dude I'm sorry I didn't know he's home I
needed to get it out of my system I'm
back being sober and blah blah blah
all right and I truly felt bad but same
time like that was awesome yeah but he
comes back and he's hanging out and it's
late night and Robert William a provider
goes on stage and Robins down and by the
main room when he walks down the hall
and he looks in he goes holy [ __ ] that
guy is still here I go yeah I feel like
I just saw a ghost like you
I can't believe it this is still a thing
just like 30 years of being a paranoid
schizophrenic doing the same Johnny
Carson style psychopath though comedy
said about marijuana and pup-pup look
look he was Don's a Nazi Skippy Shimon
was a Nazi
there was a lot of rambling
about how cuz Robert William a perv I
believed he was supposed to take over
the Tonight Show for Johnny Carson and
so when Jay Leno took over he felt that
it was because Jay is part of a Nazi
conspiracy against him and so he will
ramble about how Jay Leno is evil and
Mavis his wife Mavis is evil and he
looked but he wouldn't say Jay Leno
because that would be evil so he always
referred to him it's lemon jello you
know I'm not about to go watch lemon
jello perform The Tonight Show and I
would just sit in the front row and
laugh and everything he said that was my
role and mayhem was to be his biggest
fan and then Don Barris at some point
guys funny
okay keeps my favorite comic you I'll
show you favorite comic Don would come
down physically pick me up and at that
point I wait about a buck 45 Hewitt's
and he would pick me up over like up to
his shoulders and just heave me at
Robert Knepper via and I just go
flailing and Robert not to attack not to
attack and he always called me Erik no
matter how many times I told him my name
was Rick no I'm really sorry about that
Eric maybe he would lock himself in the
bathroom he'd have in that cool yeah
saying that same outfit every day mouth
mouth tooth yeah green green corduroy
suit the same outfit trash pad smelled
them oh it was rancid rancid but I know
the night that I was out of town they
looked a bathroom on fire to get him out
yeah and I got the call from Corey
saying did you like robbing a provide on
fire no I'm in Miami
yeah I'm not there who the [ __ ] would do
something like this I know why would you
think I would he's got to be jelly yeah
it's gotta be something like Robin it's
how I knew he was crazy yeah and by the
time Robert came and I was doing coke
yeah so he was trying to creep me out
understandably yeah but it's funny the
destroyable to tell you now it's gonna
explain a lot of things to you I have a
lot of respect with the doorman there
yeah more than some economics in some
situations yeah because you want it that
bad
right you're there watching Martin
Lawrence come in Eddie Griffin Joe Rogan
you know all these names at that time
yeah yeah that's that's those are that
we were Doren dice and those guys were
the as I said you're on Sundays she will
let me work the door and Sunday and host
okay and I would host the second part of
the thing and then I would give Dom
Barrett stuff
The Late Late movie yeah and I disappear
got a package of coke but there was you
guys were young yeah one of my best
nights there with me and I'll understand
a lot by this story I walk in one night
and a kid by the name of Johnny he's
working the door but he's working the
back door and he's watching the comics
and he says to me I want to know how to
get more spots in him and I'd watched
him during the open mic I'm like this is
a funny [ __ ] kid yeah I go so I
decided to go into Joey Diaz like well I
only make eight dollars a night that
time she's paying shift I got 25 a shift
nine hours guys 25 bucks [ __ ] yeah he
goes I'm getting shift work I need those
15 dollars so I called Duncan that day
Duncan what's going up forget he's a kid
yeah this week yeah sweet kid and he was
like Joey so what do I have to do for a
single first don't you have to give me
something like a token you're full
Godfather of fifty a hundred and he
looked at me like he was like yeah I'm
not to call my mother Mary right that's
how young yeah like that's how I'm I'm
[ __ ] dinosaur
Duncan Carroll is working at the golf
course at the time honey
yeah and Duncan came home and I go
Duncan tell him the rules break it now
and he goes yeah oh you're 15 dollars
and since Diaz brought you in Diaz gets
final hours so and and and at first you
could tell you was not happy with it
yeah he said that's my whole and there's
I'm okay and looks like I'm gonna happen
like [ __ ] you ha great that's good yeah
Ari was a kid yeah I still move being on
a [ __ ] hailstorm and getting a call
in the original box in those days people
right now Joey you gotta call an
original the only one there's no cell
phones and I'm gonna [ __ ] the cell phone
yeah I had a pager yeah haven't been
getting on that call and it was like
Austin Texas had a fall out of Sunday
night and I had called her one night
Margie out of the blue and said can I
get it and she called me and she goes
can you come to Austin be there Tuesday
and I hate and I'm like who was that on
it I got a minus 18 the back of town
right Mitzi's check though Friday and I
think I called right from the college
tour with that remember when the back
phone was in the kitchen yeah that back
from yeah downline you get long distance
issue all right but know you can make
long-distance call from there and they
started saying somebody keeps making
long-distance call from the bar yeah it
was me yeah Easter do it from the phone
room two problems ok that was the I went
and called whoever you're gonna call
like 1-800-9-4 one Delta the number one
802 to two and then you can easily be
connected for an extra additional 20
cent I gotta get to Austin they gave me
like it was this is plane tickets wall
200 right it was 200 to go everywhere
and I remember go hard was a doorman but
he was booking commercials
yeah like are any to a house Larry gave
to me goes I'm never gonna see this and
I go I promise you you gonna see this at
that time we can are
friends yeah not brothers right friends
and I member before I left I got a sag
check like a rescheduled I couldn't wait
to see him that Tuesday I'm going to use
you to allow he's like I wrote it off
and then we become friends so we became
friends I remember back then they didn't
have weed stores everywhere so he still
had to like get weed from people and so
I worked at this shitty restaurant in
Manhattan Beach but I just knew a bunch
of stoner South Bay kids who grew pot
and so one of them grew this white widow
it was just crazy good and I would bring
it up to the store and smoke everyone
out and I smoked Joey out one night he
was just like that [ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy
and I'm like yeah and you really gotta
get me some of that how am i all right
so I worked at the restaurant the next
day brought some up for you and I
remember you really like you said I
didn't bring money but can I get you
next time I see you and I'm like all
right
didn't think anything of it and I'd
already at that point like wheels had
[ __ ] me over before and my Creek and
some other guys and I just haven't been
like yeah you know I want these guys to
like me so it's cool whatever and I
didn't see you for like eight months but
you would call me like every couple
months you'd be like am I being stored
in are you there and I think now I'm on
the road with Polly any bug all right
well I got you still on my bailing
this guy really gonna still give you
money yeah you know it almost it was
almost a year it's probably like nine or
ten months before I saw you
yeah I went on the road yeah you're on
their own just I went on I ate a bag of
dick at the improv one night and it just
cracked me like you I was it's okay for
me to bomb at the Comedy Store right at
home
but the bomb away yeah it's the other
side of Hollywood i bombed them between
Nick DiPaolo and Doug Stanhope well yeah
that was a regular cats killer so I
didn't deserve to be at the store she
was just right bringing me along me I
thought I could be do spots at the
improv
I get sandwiched in between two killers
yeah and I just went on uh I went on in
fact one of the tour well I went on too
long
one was like nine months yeah and then I
was just thinking about this the one I
started but not because
was away for New Year's mm I'll cos
gonna be 20 years ago right started with
a belly room show that's the first time
I have it told stories on stage I've
been don't tell me about eight years I
lied to the belly room show Mitch he
kept saying do a belly alone showing you
the finals ahead and one of the [ __ ]
breath I thought belly room sure got
like 40 people I think I made like a
hundred bucks or something yeah
something shitty 80 bucks or something
right well I spent it all on blow and
somebody snuck a bottle of tequila and
we were crazy yeah you know and we just
won outside and goddamn it afterward and
the next day I think that I would start
with life I would fly it's like Buffalo
just do what we come in Buffalo for your
dog over to Toronto right this is pre
9/11 yeah yeah they would let me into
Toronto right do a couple one-nighters
for Yuk Yuk's come back and then go city
the city Buffalo Rochester Syracuse
right New Jersey northern New Jersey
that's real touring DC yeah but
featuring them saying yeah just banging
it out three hundred one week 150 one
week you going week the week nobody
knows nothing yeah and some of the weeks
I had yeah weeks there with there two
weeks open and I just knew something
would happen right I would end up
somewhere that's Sunday night at the
club somebody's gonna say the a what are
you gonna do Nathan well look at her
response looking for a spot long I don't
one night I'm on Tuesday my buddy one
thrown on Friday if you want to sleep on
my couch you could and there you go both
right you gotta pick up 300 and you know
so I went out just going out it's not
after that one out of the world Joey
Diaz
yeah there's no poor is dead yeah you
had anchors yeah and while you were out
you were hoping yeah not premier clubs
have [ __ ] bars the coffeehouse
Mormons do not use curse words right you
don't even know that Mormons do you get
that yeah you're working on a new bit of
sticking your dick up your wife's as
well knowing and you get there and
there's a [ __ ] woman note there's a
Mormons tonight yeah you can not use any
are rated
tario just made you switch it up yeah
what did you learn all those early years
at the store
I mean you learned from every facet you
do yeah you learned - to do what not to
do
yeah you from watching comics both good
and bad you learn what you should never
do what is a good path to take my
problem early on and I would do okay I
always did okay
you know I'd bomb some nights and I do
great some nights the most time I was
just doing okay then I I was doing what
a lot of young comics do which is I was
I was almost imitating the comics I
really liked so I wasn't writing jokes
from my perspective it would be like I
would be doing a bit and looking back
now I'm like you know what I still think
that bit would have been funny if I was
Sebastian but being me I am nothing like
Sebastian and so it just comes off
differently and would never work as me
but I wasn't writing for my perspective
I'm watching Sebastian crush every night
and going I need to write jokes like
that and so then working at the store in
doing those late-night spots and doing
even when I got opening spots or
whatever I never got good spots so
that's out of the question but I just I
was learning it took me two or three
years of learning just to be myself on
stage you know not what I thought I
should be just actually be Who I am
people would always kill you so much
funnier offstage and so it took me a
long time to forget bother you yeah Oh
tries to be mad at me crazy
and I know that people were doing the
same [ __ ] to you and you're just such a
funny person like in a conversation
really like how do I translate it they
just took it it took bombing a lot to
learn to finally be me and then once I
was me then it was you know at that
point I started doing a lot of crowd
work cuz it I just felt like such a
fraud doing the same jokes every night
and once I started doing crowd work it
really started kind of opening up my
ability to do well I started having
more sets where I was kind of crushing
and there's more and more comedians
started hating me for doing it that I'm
the type of person that I kind of get a
kick out of pissing people off
so it was like oh this this is what I
want to do so then for years that's all
I was doing it was just doing crowd work
and I you know was convincing myself you
know someone will let me do Comedy
Central with this kind of thing and then
it took another five years before my oh
no one no one's ever gonna let me do
that on Comedy Central because they want
to know every word you're gonna say
let's start writing jokes again getting
back into doing some material but I
still am very heavy with crowd work
because I feel like that's that's my
specialty
yeah that's what I'm good at and it's
it's not just talking to people and you
know making fun of them all that some of
it but talking to people inspires random
stupid funny things in my brain that you
know kind of become bits I guess and
it's just it's kind of developed into
how Comedy Works most authentically for
me so you look very organic up there
doing it yeah which is the number one
thing when you do have yeah is you want
it to be as organic that could be you
know I think she is to learn yeah what
is organic for those words to naturally
come out of you when you see Doug
Stanhope say that word and you try to
mimic that word it's not naturally
coming out he it's a funny word there's
words or the funny it's right for yes
but that process that you learn at the
store I picked up a bad habit in New
York when I went to New York and I used
to hope there would I would take if
they're even engage knowing I had eight
minutes of material counting on totally
two minutes of hey now you don't know
where you're from
right I got pretty good at it yeah I got
pretty good at it 30 economy 48 calmly I
was still writing but that was my go-to
was improvising I don't know what the CI
I was really doing it right I was
walking and making a living of it by
knew two things it was 50/50 right it
was easy to destroy it was it'll be a
long night right then I got that way
that this calm restored then like two
years to find my voice at the store I'm
lucky that she stuck it out of me for
two years as a comic you go through a
lot of [ __ ] like that
going from a road feature to becoming a
Comedy Store regular there's a lot of
mysticism that goes through yet right so
the first thing they tell you is not to
talk to the audience yeah okay and then
it's like you have this you know you're
not supposed to talk to the audience but
you do it and I kept doing at the store
I kept going through all these phases of
tonight I'm gonna say a bit and let them
pause before I go into the next I did
experimental [ __ ] sure I two years
it cost bombing experimental and the
comedy world means bombing yeah don't
ever get those words confused
yeah well a scientist is doing
experiment he's doing it for something
positive
well the comedian is experimenting
that's the equivalent of of saying we're
gonna go bomb oh yeah like I'm gonna be
experimenting with some things unless
you have a cat a lab coat on you read
the sucking dick or you're bombing with
my friend world
yeah and that was the thing that I
wanted my percentage just to get higher
so little by little I want away from
talking to the audience and that time in
Jersey when I was already regular I was
already at regular and I was doing
analyzed that and I took the week in
Jersey for a film I called the guy and
told him I'm shooting this movie so
right away he wanted to hire made sure
and he made me a feature for a headline
and that was the big that was it that
was 202 if I think analyze that came out
in 203 yeah I was still doing the thing
but now I was doing that the story
oh yeah Kraft is his home and read those
started coming in yeah he was very good
at that but veni favorito really wasn't
improvising he was pre right no he was
all set yeah it's like Don Rickles stop
using it for free but that's the gift
yeah you have to make it seem like it's
happening today
yeah but the first time you'll see when
fini if every door next night you're
like improvising you bum Charles
Fletcher would do that - yes
Charles yeah she would do that like I
first time watching like holy [ __ ] this
dude is quick and the second I'm like
wait a goddamn second
yeah hurt your feelings like if you'll
see your favorite comic bomb that's one
thing yeah but to see your favorite
bombing your comic do you think dupe
today yeah this guy [ __ ] lied to me I
saw the line on the pigeon yes well as a
young comic who I don't really do any
crowd work it and sent it seems like
such a risk to do all crowd work because
I mean I do bits from weeks and months
before I tried out in a real show and
for you to just say what's on top of
your head at a real show for the first
time like I used to 5050 to me it's even
like 25 Sony like there's such a big
risk of it bombing that I would like
that I don't even want to take that risk
so to to hear that you like you're just
completely going up there cold is
amazing explain that improvising is it
something you choose yeah it was wising
is something that one night you realize
you're in a jam yeah you're in a jam you
do it yeah you definitely doing it
you're you know you're you're teaching
yourself to swim you're drowning but
it's uh you know 12 it's one of those
things where it's truly you either have
the mind and it's gonna work or you
don't like I've had so many comics tell
me like did anyone could do crowd work
and blah blah and I go alright I've
never seen you do crowd work though I
can do it and then they go up and they
do like two minutes of bombing doing
crowd work and they just go straight
back to the material
it just wasn't working like yes cuz you
can't do it but I know I'm not gonna say
who it was I don't even remember the
guys name but I saw one guy do like 25
minutes of possibly like the worst crowd
we're gonna it hurts as an audience yeah
because he it would so add to give you a
little compliment I started going to the
store before I even my Joey and when I
would see you on the on the line if I
loved it but I would also be like all
cameras in the back a little bit because
because he's [ __ ] because you're good
yeah and then then I don't know how many
years ago you didn't stop but you you
didn't do it as you didn't do it as much
I would kind of like Sam's like oh yeah
I missed I missed the crowd work yeah
that's what a lot of people would tell
me when I started because there was a
couple years where I was just trying to
do material and it was fine cuz now I'm
more sure of who I am so my material is
more authentically me I guess but people
be I just you know it was nice because
I'm at the store all the time and you
see the comics doing the same bits but
it was cool cuz I knew at least you
would be different right okay yeah but
it's just it I it truly makes me feel
better when I am going up there
free-minded just like this is what I
want to do you know like not having it
all planned out like it I feel more
accomplished doing a set of almost all
crowd work than I do
material not that I think doing material
is bad because I do like doing that as
well now but it's a you know I've
watched so many people bomb doing it
there's a guy doorguy remember Jimmy
Pitt yes love Jimmy piss your car goes
Chicago nice kid nice kid super funny
offstage great kid
he's still contacted yeah hadn't talked
to him this time he lives in Florida now
okay that's what yeah he was in Buffalo
for a while and I lives in Florida I
remember watching him do crowd work one
night in the o.r and all the comics in
the back just dying but it just there
was just nothing to it there's no
substance to his crowd or Q be like you
know where are you from some of the New
Orlean
New Orleans ain't never been there and
then that was the end of it we're all
it's like well that's your reference is
that you've never been there but it
would do it literally was destroying all
the comics in the back all of us just
losing our [ __ ] laughing in the crowd
just like what the [ __ ] is going on have
you ever thought of something so quickly
that would others your words the insides
almost break yeah that you I he walk off
there and I'm gonna forget being in the
store and dying and improvising yeah
just look like something gone way your
friend when you're dead mark and me go
on I did a book report on you extra
sixth grade I did a book report on
Denmark yeah I had to get encyclopedia
rip the pages and staple them and take
them home yeah but no it's uh
that's just brain Association though and
that's you know as well as things like
just saying a grown man you especially
saying that you did a book report on
something is [ __ ] hysterical it's a
truth yeah the truth and in you're just
saying line out there cuz that's what
you're thinking like damn I don't know
[ __ ] about you other than the [ __ ]
book report
but you saying that it's [ __ ]
hysterical it's an experience hold on
one second I gotta ask you some more
questions
yeah and now for a word from our
sponsors listen the Church of what's
happened now is sponsored to you by
policy genius Halloween is right around
the corner but you the thing that really
scares uncle Joey shopping for life
insurance I hate this [ __ ] but getting
life insurance doesn't need to be
difficult or expensive right now prices
are the lowest they've been in twenty
years
that's what policy genius comes in it's
the easy way to shop and compare prices
for insurance online just go to policy
genius.com right now and in minutes you
can compete compare quotes from the top
and insurance so you can get a right
amount of coverage for the best possible
price and policy genius doesn't make
life insurance easy they can also help
you find the right home insurance auto
insurance and disability insurance once
you apply
they'll handle all the paperwork for you
listen getting quotes making calls going
from webpage the webpage it's a [ __ ]
pain yes go to policy genius.com right
now this is Toba take the scariness out
of buying life insurance you need it
head to policy genius calm today and
compare quotes and apply in minutes you
can do the whole thing on your phone
right now five minutes policy genius the
way to buy life insurance get it at
policy genius calm and tell them uncle
Joey sent you stay black another issue
there's three guys at the store but I
knew and this is why I did what I did
error me up there's three guys at the
store that if you looked at on paper
they were not gonna do well you know I
had intense extensive conversation yeah
about road work people trying to take
him on the road yeah and it was just I I
I did riddles in Chicago once and you
know I said the guy who owned it and
booked it would come to the Comedy Store
and hang out young okay tell me sir yeah
Brian Brian he's done that yeah he's out
he's got out the checks yeah he he said
I'll you know I brought someone so and
so and so and they were great and you
know I love Brian Holtzman so I brought
him out and the crowd just hated him he
said it was just brutal it's so bad yes
outside and see was so bad that Holtzman
was just back I'm not I'm not performing
tomorrow he was like come on just call
me you know you can do the feature I'm
not performing here forget it he's that
ultimate bomb so bad the two shows on
Friday night I think he eventually did
it but brain essentially had to be like
convinced and like dude just just come
tomorrow it'll be fine and I think he
had a feature instead of headline to
switch the feature in the headliner but
Chicago was just not down with
Reinholds I'm ready yeah and they that
you know you've had some problems in the
road
yeah and my first couple years on the
road you know I had tons of people
telling me not to call back
really we enjoyed you for the weekend
but not really right we got a lot of
complaints yeah and then it went from so
then I became a regular at the store and
I started trimming off the fat right you
learned from watching other guys that
are at your level that's what's really
important at the store that yeah you
guys listen to you the class that you'll
witness you know and just because you
were a dog I like you had Brent with you
that walked in with you and Sebastian
yeah it was a hell of a class it really
was one of the most well the best
classes that were walk in there yeah it
was great and I was like the brush with
us yeah yeah like you you guys meshed
with us right away we were like 10 years
older but yeah it was the best class
like that Rick Ramos right the guy that
got really chubby
jasonlew oh say some JLo yeah JLo you
know this is family
yeah Richie Richie Taylor Richie
what the funniest man to never do comedy
Dawg you know Richie tell it was [ __ ] on
Sundays yeah Sunday's was a different
night up there it was getting you dick
going deep night you late wall on
Sundays at the store or [ __ ] ah you
are doing it right like people will
[ __ ] get [ __ ] up yeah I still
remember being out there for in the
morning with Eddie Griffin talking about
a thousand samurais killed Bruce Lee but
one of them touched him and I'm in a
rain and he died right oh my god this is
the reason i snort coke i mean daddy was
always there till we yeah that reasoning
was why when i bombed after Nick DiPaolo
and Stanhope that night I did the first
or it slipped my memory he was like nine
months yeah stayed out there and then
the tour of 2000 started the first week
of November and went all the way to LA
completely Wow
so I would even know how to count to
Josh Wolf's house right I just
disappeared
every six weeks I'd send clothes home I
go to on the Walmart and get a couple of
shirts I tried to see these home get new
batteries for the DVD player and I just
had Greyhound will travel Wow though
compounding it no credit card
there was no ATM card right it was cash
hope notebook a pen and have couch will
travel right and I knew that if I came
back before that I wouldn't stay at the
store I had a B so I took what I learned
at the store you know on the road you
can expand and expand the huh then when
you come back to LA you've cut it back
down right now all of a sudden you lose
clone image you can't do that joke about
to Peter no more I gotta write that off
yeah all these jokes that you picked up
nine months on the road sure it was a
real experience for me and that's why I
think I don't or Rogan started taking me
out that's cemented in it with people
right until then I was really going out
to get beat up yeah
until from from 91 to 2001 and to I was
going on the road to get beat up like I
stayed in rooms that the glass was
broken right and Alaska you know we
stayed in the back room of a band room
yeah
come on the beds I did it the snow was
coming through the [ __ ] window I
don't know I wonder if it's the same
place I'd show Charlie's oh yeah and I
did a place called the shed and they
just put you in a little condo above the
bar and I was there I think it's
February and the window in the living
room was shattered so it's just like
negative ten
Gries air in the living room of the
condo I just remember being like get the
windows broken that yeah it's been
broken since like September I'm like oh
sorry I remember like in the the bedroom
had closed the door and then I'd stuffed
the towel on the door so the cold air
wouldn't blow in and then I just had
every blanket in the condo on me just
dying like is this worth it oh my god
tips in New York kind of bananas and
they just hated the comic so they would
put you downstairs they you know the
windows will come with snow yeah all day
freezing to give you 30% off at the
restaurant you didn't want to eat their
food was so bad and it was next to a gas
station that was your life Monday you
availa at the restaurant or you at the
gas station there was like Indian people
and then we give you those Hindu eggs
right with fairy dust on them yeah yeah
well you know waking up with a [ __ ]
hangover from the night before an
austin-healey eat these courage [ __ ]
eggs [ __ ] you just eat Cheetos [ __ ]
gas station with a hot dog yeah and that
[ __ ] didn't look too good now one of the
worst weeks ever was the old Kansas City
Club it was a block away from my odors
yeah a gas station yeah
and hazardous breakfasts breakfast it
the whole town that was it was confident
though it was yogurt a banana a little
box full maybe yellow box of Syria there
was no eggs then yeah it was no toast
and there was no muffins then that free
breakfast enough so you lived on you
stole like ten bananas yeah and you
brought them up to the room and
hopefully the headliner if you went to
the radio with him paint stop somewhere
and that judge you sound like CVS or
yeah you got like you know bottled
waters or [ __ ] it you know it was you
know you're living on five hours a week
and you the plane ticket comes out of
that right that's your toughest period
of your life yeah that's better why I
say you got to do 15 of those
yeah I'll do 15 those on your room to
really grow to really grow make sure you
want it just make its not know how to
get a hundred a set time five you know
yeah Tom Segura said some months ago
those I can't believe comedy clubs are
still paying on your asset to feed you
yeah I saw him put a one hundred assent
and they cut out the hotel yeah
that's why I can't like it's not worth
it for me to feature anymore it's
because I can make I do if I do main
room Friday and Saturday at the Comedy
Store
I'll make about six hundred bucks five
to six hundred bucks and I don't have to
fly anywhere I go anywhere and if I
someone wants me to come feature in
Indianapolis to see you know what we
need to see you it's like I'm going to
end up spending money I got to pay for
child care like it's just it's endless
I'm gonna lose money to go do it so the
feature world has been the cheek the
feature world was never really a great
world to be in yeah especially when you
into the Midwest with some of the
Booker's that just do one night but the
feature world is just to improve yeah a
lot of different cities but in a
different culture time yeah you know
you're going to deeper holes yeah well I
wouldn't go at this level right now sure
you'd go with the default like you go
into Billings Montana right other one in
Montana where you know I'm thinking
about going to Billings next year cuz I
used to go there well nobody goes the
billion yes have a thousand [ __ ]
comedy fans fun it's a little back
country but it's fun fun they were doing
150 miles an hour to a couple years yeah
they're not gonna get offended by jokes
which is beautiful no no that wait yeah
they come up there yeah you look up
Montana there's really no comedy room no
I guarantee it's whatever trouble that
there's no yeah there's no population to
keep saying like I I guarantee you could
draw there but there would never be a
club that could just you know look you
and then have three weeks of guys who
aren't known because there wouldn't be a
crowd to go do it but all those cities
are small they're looking for something
to do on a Friday night very true even
the one they opened up an Alabama then
they open up a club in Alabama
yeah zany so go on
it's uh right over it's right over its
four hours in Tennessee yeah and it was
great it's the same I got the same
company has one in Arizona and right
yeah Liberty yeah it's lovely yeah it's
great
it's a great room yeah heard freely he
brings cheesesteaks and you know
hilarious rise but even those clocks
I've always admired those clubs because
they start providing something yes it's
very easy to open up a club in Atlanta
but then you gotta go and think about
some other clubs yeah you open up some
where nobody else is well you're the
holy [ __ ] thing yeah it's gonna take
you six months to establish yourself
yeah especially if you open up in June
right like Montana Utah you know this
city is that you're not gonna draw
during this summer Buffalo everyone's
gonna be out Buffalo every August he
goes in his pocket he loses every other
yeah the club in Alaska that I performed
that didn't do shows at all during the
summer yeah because you know they get 20
hours of daylight during the summer so
everyone is outside the whole time and
then during the winter they get two
hours a day of sunlight so people are
ready to laugh cuz you can't go outside
there's negative 30 degrees when I
landed I just remember be like what the
[ __ ] am I doing here what was the date
you walked into the store if it would
have been beginning of October of 2002 I
had lived in LA for four days the first
time I did open mic the Comedy Store and
it took me about two months to get a job
and then I started working right right
before New Year's 2002 and I worked
there for two and a half years until
Paulie fired me while I was on the road
with Paulie they didn't get a door shift
covered he called me on like on Tuesday
so dude we're going to Charlotte bro I
go alright so yeah right it's easy
booked the commercial dude you got to go
with me all right cool I got my Thursday
shift covered I got my Saturday shift
covered but no only cover my Friday
shifts I'm like no
told Dean no one will do it if you can
find someone didn't think anything of it
what's Charlotte it shows Thursday night
things are great it shows Friday night
things are great Saturday afternoon meet
Polly for lunch it's like dude you
didn't get your door shift covered oh
yeah I want to do it I told Dean sorry
did fired me on the road and I'm like
that sucks and then apart me it's like I
work nine hours at night for $25 I don't
think this is a loss necessarily I was
already established at the store so
you're I was gonna get my times yeah
yeah all right whatever that's cool I
started working other random [ __ ] jobs
when I was in town and stuff but and
then Polly still took me on the road
with them for another year probably
before I got good enough that he had to
fire me
classic classic headliner move I guess
so you've been going in and out of that
dump in 17 years yeah I when I say dump
I say it like it's a beautiful yeah
absolutely it's a beautiful place you
become a man in there absolutely have a
family though you have a wife and a
child
yeah that my wife had the Comedy Store
how you happy that you chose this path
absolutely there isn't anything else I
would rather be starting for were you
reaching to be an engineer I mean I
could tell you about stupid good stock
honestly growing up I wanted to you know
I guess I was like a lot of kids I
wanted to be an athlete but I was always
tiny by time I was in high school it was
very apparent I wasn't ever gonna play
basketball or baseball the things I
loved I was a distance runner not a lot
of money and distance running so I went
to college for a film school I saw you
know I'm gonna go to college yeah I went
first year I went to a small arts
college called college of Santa Fe in
New Mexico okay and it just was kind of
shady it soceity like Ryan Mervis went
there Annie Lederman went there and so
shady that it's the only College I've
ever heard of that closed like there's
straight closed the college
maybe 10 years ago yes not working so
they closed it and then they reopened it
under a different name and then that had
went bankrupt again and they
miraculously burned to the ground but
went there for a year made some friends
the guy whose couch I slept on when I
first moved to LA was a guy Matt
freshman year of college at college to
Santa Fe and then I transferred to Kay
you went to ku4 long yeah up in Lawrence
look at you [ __ ] loving it look at
you they sling in that go hey you tons
of drugs into it and like people I see
you have a lot of friends Lawrence I got
you know what I knew a teen drug dealers
and I probably had five friends but you
know I was always calling somebody
yeah I definitely had a good time and
started doing comedy when I was at Kay
you and like I said when I was 21 I was
out you'd ever finished never finished
told my parents you know I'm really good
mom I'm not yeah
and I said I don't know what the point
of doing this is I wanna get a film
degree from Kay you and then move to LA
it's worth the same as nothing so I like
someone's gonna be like you graduated
from University of Kansas film school
come direct a movie this is like man no
connections there wasn't I was literally
getting nothing out of I went to film
school there for two years I never saw a
camera it's basically just film history
I had to take 10,000 classes about we're
gonna show you Citizen Kane today notice
the lighting how impressive it's the
lighting I don't give a [ __ ] about
Citizen Kane show me a [ __ ] goddamn
movie that would inspire anybody today
but look they do a zoom can you imagine
the zoom this is groundbreaking I'm like
yeah but that was 70 years ago it was a
[ __ ] about the first time someone zoomed
a lens teach me how to make a [ __ ]
movie well if you make it to senior year
you might get into classes I was like I
might get into classes waiting around
for the shit's crazy if you just come
out here at 18 ya get a job as an ad
yeah you'll move up faster by the time
you
[ __ ] 21 you'll have somebody teaching
you the business and stat guaranteed
people don't if you got a half a
heartbeat yeah you really want don't say
that yeah I've always wanted to shoot
movies in Kamali and they make you do a
cable and you [ __ ] choke yeah
I'm talking if you're ready and willing
to shoot movies you just come on here
you'll get a giant people who have done
it
yeah 20 P that'sthat's the easiest route
yeah that's easy you start they teach
you all over again anyway peach all
along yeah yeah what are you wasting and
eighty thousand hang out with your
buddies in Manhattan to shoot short
films listen I know a thousand people
who shoot short films you don't want to
end up in the short toilet you know
they're shot 20 short films I can't tell
you where they all been I saw a kid on
Facebook the other day that I love daily
but he's [ __ ] because God made
especially comedy-wise yeah and he is
always shooting these movies and it's
like why do you keep post them on
Facebook ya know I took a picture with
the chick that the movie was shot in
Vegas and you could tell the chicken
sucked eighty dicks why she just got
already have to shoot this film yeah and
she wasn't in a drug ring she was a
sperm reassure how to get an idea
stomach they put a tight dress on and
she had rolls and she had lumps and I'm
like uh all those movies you're just
wasting your time
yeah 2007 to 2010 I would get a request
to do well over a week yeah and I would
say behind there will make it easy for
you we'll shoot it close to you have
listen it's not even warranted yeah
beat that well what's what he done doing
it yeah oh my cousin sister's boyfriend
works for and that Netflix and she said
if we bring them this in six weeks then
when you do it you bring it on
they quit dancing over the TN and
they're not even working whatever no
more so now you got this stupid thing I
know a thousand p conservatively yeah
between short films specials films that
they remortgage their homes for yep you
know
they never else yeah no I used to get a
lot of people about yeah we're gonna do
this short film and I got alright so
what's the deal well we're gonna try and
enter it into some festivals don't go
okay and then the other thing I noticed
like I knew some people who made short
films that they used basically to try
and you know sell an idea to a studio or
whatever it was and so then I'd have
friends were like yeah I got this small
part in the short and you know they're
pitching it to so-and-so and then they
make it and it's kind of crappy but what
you know it looks nice I guess they used
the right equipment and then they pitch
it whatever studio they were selling for
and they buy it for a little bit of
money and any extra money that have they
used to hire people who are not people
who made the short film yes so you
basically just gave someone else a break
and I don't Kuby I'd listen to the adage
is this this is it write it down if you
want as it works first time shame on you
second time shame on me I did 20 of them
I did them for the experience but yeah
struggling comic Montreal there mommy
couldn't find an agent the only way I
could get it is through the back door
yeah I thought still where I am so I'm
not doing it I did one that was very
Mabi that would dad Fox you know Fox has
different divisions yeah great food Red
Bulls on the set you know yeah
red camera I mean these people spent
money on the short film which is an idea
that Fox had picked up and then we're
gonna sell it and then they felt that
the movie the idea for TV was a bit
rough it was two gay gangsters okay were
they wrong yeah it would have worked
with the headquarters was a pink
pussycat on Santa Mustang we had a movie
theater you know and it was a great idea
all the way through one the gay Film
Festival I was like yeah
they still play it on the game Network
what's the logo logo they still play it
people help me but just saw you I'm logo
oh my god
you know I did that one can I do another
one that while I was shooting it I heard
one person a friend of mine that they
were negotiating that script for a
bigger studio the director was unsettled
so he wanted to shoot it immediately
right with them making a low budget
which a lot of people didn't get paid
which I was one of those people he sold
the movie they did it and they did
exactly what you you know I mean these
people gonna pay me a hundred a day and
they were like hi we're starting
rehearsal on Monday the 8th day lovely
rehearsal for what what is this Oklahoma
yeah but I I didn't sign up for a blind
rehearsal yeah no rehearsals it yeah I
went back and forth for eight hours yeah
like pop a little garnish for a hundred
a day well I did spider-man 2 they paid
me scale there was no rehearsing
yeah so you want to rehearse you come
down to my house and I'll do verse over
he's lying with you they were furious
and I mean it was retired was a horrible
lingo yeah a [ __ ] monkey could do it
yeah you didn't need no [ __ ] acting
classes and I'm about my back apart I
don't like this and I've been here 10 11
12 years I'm a nurse yeah sure enough I
did the movie we did the film from
screenings that I go I don't want to go
but I bumped into look three other
mobsters one band an audition you all
there for commercial yeah did they call
you and I'm like no they call none of us
I know what you expect look at the
direct he was a scumbag yeah he was out
of USC film school he thought he was
[ __ ] Johnny Bananas yeah I just
checked on oh about three years ago now
is it fair yeah he's done I'm gonna be
Quentin Tarantino though he's worked in
a [ __ ] one-bedroom that's crazy
Granada Hills how you quit your dream
after that much commitment yeah I looked
at it was 2009 they are dissipated for
2009 did that wonder the studio phone
must have [ __ ] it up with the studio
yeah and then they all talk so once you
really [ __ ] someone over so how exactly
tomorrow night I'm excited man
you know like I said I just wanted to be
able to do an extended set here for a
long time and film it have something put
out so I can hopefully start building
somewhat of a fan base and how old is
your baby now she's three little he's
beautiful
little bastard I see the pictures that
you put up and it she so we taught her
I thought her my name cuz I think it's
important you know if they get lost or
whatever be able to say mommy daddy's
name whatever so I she knows my name and
the other day she comes in I'm cooking
her dinner you know I do got cook and do
all that stuff for she comes in she goes
daddy I need my mop a baby off the shelf
I go alright I'll get it for you in a
second I'm cooking this give me two
minutes she goes fine takes a few steps
back stands in the kitchen just staring
at me disappointed just sitting there
then she goes
Rick get the Muppet baby off the shelf I
go whoa whoa we don't you don't call me
Rick cuz that's your name it is but you
you call me daddy I'm daddy fine yeah
just attitude runway where did this come
from yeah she's in preschool there's
another girl named Julia so she broke
something I think at preschool and
blamed the other julia said no wasn't me
it was the other Julia got away with it
and so then at home she started she was
standing on one of her toys or breaking
or something I get off there you're
gonna break it she goes I didn't do it
it was the author Julia I go doesn't
Julia isn't here it was you it was you
no it wasn't me just wouldn't give up a
lot you're learning life quick city girl
where are you living
well I live out Calabasas really yeah
okay you like it up there love it it's
nice it's like the drive it's a bit of a
drive how many nights you come down the
store now um like three or four so can
you believe you were gone this can you
believe you am I 17 years later having
this
it's it's kind of what I used to look
like you like he'll not he's not he's
not gonna baby her baby will not I first
met you oh my days were numbered yeah my
skin was greenish I just saw another
picture yeah I remember one night
standing up the front patio with Duncan
Trussell and you walked up poor and
sweat and you go and you guys do coke
and Duncan goes I do you go you gotta
take this I can't if I if I hold on to
this I'm gonna do it all and use hand
dunk in a bag dung it's like thanks and
then you walk away I'm just like oh and
then Duncan's like all right I'm out of
here I guess you'd just disappear to the
bag whatever I had that one
yeah heroin volute pills just give it
the doctor was like my key on the life
commercials ya wanna immediately I do
I'm like oh you know I guess Duncan's
taking it okay what time tomorrow night
it's uh 10:30 on Thursday and dirty
mainland mainland third sunset yeah i'll
i richard pryor on sunsets right no
pressure biggest names got to live up to
that hype yeah should be good hopefully
people will come out something at oh
that you having a hard time I might take
you out with me listen [ __ ] ramen you
know people go to a mint people on the
road yeah i pow it's [ __ ] savage like
you so yeah I don't I'm terrible at all
the business side so you know I've never
had a manager or an agent or anything
always just been flying solo and you
know [ __ ] up the world the best I can
are you over there at all things comedy
they'll take you to carry those guys are
the best comedy managers there off yeah
good ever best people know where all
those gotta sell all right [ __ ]
me I'll be I got no date yeah I got dick
till November 7 to Motor City casino in
Detroit oh [ __ ] and then November 8 I'm
at the funny bone in Omaha I'm not
[ __ ] around before I wrap this show up
I want to talk to you people about some
listen
baseball playoffs the World Series you
got football you got college football
and you're sitting there telling me
you're [ __ ] bro
go [ __ ] yourself I'm sitting here with
my bookie dot AG you're over there
sitting telling your grandmother and all
your friends I went three for four
I went 4 for 9 do something about it
[ __ ] put your money where your mouth is
let me tell you some of my bookie that
AG they got better the sentence and more
lines than any other sports book period
and this year they're running a super
contest on an allowance to enter you
picked five teams a week against the
spread you rack up the points 1st place
is guaranteed on $1,000 where the [ __ ]
are you gonna get that action from no
Mary
they just revamped their site it's
looking [ __ ] tremendous so go take a
look if you haven't already listen we
got a plethora of games this weekend
we got Baseball World Series you got em
beat and not MBA but you got preseason
for you thumping degenerates ain't
managed 1-800 gambler get your life
together but if you want to [ __ ] play
the win and that's what you're looking
to do my book is the way to go cuz you
play you win you get paid and today eww
you're the first deposit they'll double
your first deposit prude use promo code
Church to get 100 percent bonus on your
initial deposit up to $1,000 who's
better than you nobody visit my bookie
dad AG today that's my bookie doll AG
and don't forget to use promo code
Church when you're creating your
[ __ ] account to claim your
bonus coz with my bookie you play you
win you get paid and there's a time of
the year where you really money your kid
needs [ __ ] rollerskates the church is
also brought to you by policy genius
comms in minutes you and compare quotes
from top and insurance so you can get
the right amount of coverage at the best
possible price and policy genius just
doesn't make life insurance easy no they
can also help you find the right auto
home and disability insurance once you
apply they'll handle all the paperwork
for you listen how only ins you're
around the corner but one thing that
really scares me
is [ __ ] shopping French good
insurance and it scares the [ __ ] out of
you too right now
insurance prices are the lowest they've
been in 20 years and that's what policy
genius.com comes in right now
this October take the scariness out of
buying life insurance head to policy
genius.com
today to compare quotes and apply in
minutes you can do the whole thing on
your phone right now couple swipes
couple clicks policy genius the way to
buy life insurance get to get it at
policy genius.com and tell them uncle
Joey sent you the church is also brought
to you by one of my favorites because
it's about health it's like right now
you know if you don't wanna dentist and
clean your [ __ ] mouth you might die
have a heart attack because that plaque
goes to your heart that's what they say
what are you doing you got a dirty dick
that affects everything you when your
boss smell and it creeps into you
[ __ ] you can't even buy some [ __ ]
little Chinese chick to lick your ass in
Mexico for the small money just you
gotta start taking care your self
everybody wants their [ __ ] licked but
nobody wants to wipe a little [ __ ]
butt deodorizer the same both for your
balls and the same goes for your love
stick listen that dick ain't daddy
[ __ ] pro comment what's that word
procreate that dick game for procreation
it's for Sukkot especially during
Halloween there's nothing better than a
virus sucking your dick on Halloween
tell me I'm lying uncle Joey's here to
let you know with this Halloween keep
the cobwebs despite his the lice out of
your [ __ ] dick [ __ ] sack and clean
that [ __ ] mojo stick before she sucks
your tailpipe my friends over at
manscape created the tool you need to
shave your balls with it's called a lawn
mower 2.0 I use it myself I'm about to
do a lot of a little Halloween trimming
which I'll make a video for you
[ __ ] for this week I'm saying
you're ready to see how I said my
nutsack with the manscape [ __ ] lawn
mower 2.0 they drew away the 2.0 why
does the people likely he's got that Jew
hair down there he don't be a don't
condition it you even a lawn mower can't
cut Jews balls asli's balls in but with
[ __ ] manscape 2.0 he's good to go
it's a skin save technology for you mow
mows in the back that means it won't
Nick
or snag your ball sack no stitches you
understand me
you ever have a girl only suck one
[ __ ] nut because the other ones got
stitches on it you don't need that
aggravation
plus it's perfect to travel and it's
easy to charge you get manscape wherever
you go you could do it one-handed while
your finger banging your wife with the
other hand manscape will get your
[ __ ] slung looking nice and shiny
remember you trim the [ __ ] yard the
tree limbs bigger right or wrong that's
what I'm trying to tell you you want to
get your dick sucked on Halloween trick
the treat [ __ ] manscape lawn
mower 2.0 this is the way to go and if
this is the first time you've considered
manscaping they got the deal for you the
perfect package comes with a lawn mower
and a safety razor plus to trim those
little [ __ ] stubborn hairs down by
the bottom of your dick and underneath
remember when you pick up your nutsack
you get that little roller hand looks
like you're Johnny Mohican you can shave
that down so when they stick their
tongue in your ass it's like a chocolate
bonbon all they taste is lunch and skin
the perfect package comes with a lot
more the safety razor plus and a crop
preserver especially formulated the
Ottoman see it balls no stains and the
Reviver when you're an old man like me
and balls crunch up all day you got your
underwear you hit it with the revive of
the spritz this spritz and tones and
refreshes your junk and it keeps it cool
it's like they're smelling bengay they
know you're old you know I'm saying
with the perfect package your pouch will
be prouder than you and your pole will
be perfect what else what else what are
you living for are you living for I like
riding horses listen I like my dick suck
and if you like your getting your dick
sucked like uncle Joey you got a
manscape okay plain and simple now the
church can get 20% off your first
daughter when you use promo code church
at manscape calm if you want the perfect
package they're gonna throw on a free
travel bag for you [ __ ] but you
gotta use promo code Church si-hu rc8
that's manscape calm use promo code
Church 20% off your first door the new
ladies you know
your little [ __ ] bats could use a
little trimming for the [ __ ] holidays
you might as well live it up like guys
get the lawnmower trim that [ __ ] Bush
so you don't have those little side
things when I'm eating [ __ ] your cheek
gets caught in one of those hairs that
grow sideways I got friends that got
scars look like Indians because they got
[ __ ] things so you can use manscape
on your little skanky monkey - all right
so anyway I want to thank manscape
I wanted thing policy genius.com and I
also want to thank my bookie for always
having her back and helping us bring
this podcast to you I want that Rick
Ingram
do not forget to support Rick England
tomorrow night Thursday night the
[ __ ] Comedy Store 10:30 show
all things calmly a lot of people
walking around while action don't
support this guy this guy's earned his
[ __ ] stripes he's not some [ __ ]
Mook that [ __ ] putting up on YouTube
and now they like him because he's
singing Arabs law was a playing what is
that this [ __ ] a real deal I
love them with all my heart thank you
very much for having me I want to thank
you guys for listening I want to thank
you guys for love and for [ __ ] always
having her back and don't forget you got
the world by the balls it's up to you
why [ __ ] around like the rest of these
non-gluten [ __ ] take what's
yours go get a gun whatever you need to
do [ __ ] it eat some ass
trick-or-treat I love your [ __ ]
see you Monday morning tip top Magoo
check this [ __ ] your meal Lee